oh
bonjour bienvenue dans ce canal tv
spéciale championnat du monde et encore
avec jany chabanon notre invité
décidément super championnat voilà on
est très intéressant dans ce championnat
toujours suivi ce championnat notamment
qui suivit aussi sur ton site tu avais
chaque académie
oui on parla fou du championnat
évidemment donc on suit l'événement de
près voilà donc championnat du monde
alors on a vu les parties 9 et 10
superbe
on peut dire que topalov prend
l'avantagé tout de suite après il se
fait il se fait contrer
voilà exactement donc topalov donc qui
est bien remonté bon il a quand même
toujours ce point cette fameuse partie
manquante donc on ne connaît toujours
pas le véritable issue car c'est parce
que je crois que légalement pour la fidh
en tout cas elle est admise comme
forfait donc voilà pour la fidh on peut
casser comme ça un prof pour la fille
d'après bon après ça sera une serait
quelque chose qui risque de passer
devant les tribunaux si si kramnik
perdait le match
oui voilà ces mêmes même s'ils gagnent
je pense qu'il puisse qu'il l'a dit de
toute façon qu'il entamera une procédure
en justice jugeant même si le ganil peu
il peut protester sur le fait qu'on
qu'on l'a mis devant un fait accompli
voilà donc je pense que c'est possible
on peut noter que notamment dans le
football ça arrive que des fois des
résultats soient inversés par les
tribunaux c'est déjà arrivé je veux dire
c'est pour des raisons de
où est donc pour les échoppes pour
rapport voilà c'est possible ce serait
possible de toute façon paniqué quand
même proposer une solution qui est quand
même assez assez juste à est assez assez
intéressante pour pour les spectateurs
pour la fédération pour le jeu d'échecs
c'est de continuer le match la faune et
après de voir ça dans les tripes voilà
c'est à dire mais en n'acceptant pas la
hauteur de la scène pour la lire kg il
continue mais sous protestation alors
résultat on arrive maintenant la 11e
partie donc on arrive à la fin du match
est toujours égalité donc si les deux
hommes n'arrivent pas à se départager
d'ici la fin il risque d'y avoir des tie
break ce qui serait unique dans
l'histoire des championnats du monde
en tout cas classique oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'en match en match qu'on
dit avant un match de 12 partis comme ça
on n'a jamais vu de deux tie-breaks on
en a vu un match de six parties me
semble entraînant des cartes peuvent
tout à fait et puis et puis c'est tout
comme géo sinon on a vu évidemment des
tie break dans l'est dans les matches
des championnats du monde descend
de la fidh puisque c'étaient des micros
match mais mais là on n'en est pas là en
tout cas pour l'instant il reste encore
deux parties topalov ali blanc c'est la
onzième alors est-ce que quelle va être
la stratégie de topalov maintenant pour
cette troisième partie est ce qu'il va
essayer de gagner absolument il va
essayer de passer de terminer ce match
en gagnant est
c'est qu'est-ce qu'ils vont vraiment
prendre des risques ce niveau à ce
moment là du match alors qu'il reste
deux parties topalov will topalov va
tenter quelque chose va essayer de
surprendre encore une fois de surprendre
son adversaire par à part quelque chose
de nouveau puisqu'il a joué toujours d
c'était comme le joueur le plus le plus
innovant de ce match il faut voir que
bon les nouveautés de topalov sont
parfois bonne parfois moins bonnes
donc là est-ce qu'il a encore quelque
chose est-ce qu'il a une arme secrète à
sortir on veut le voir alors on va
l'avoir dernière fois pour topalov
pour avoir les blancs dans ce match eh
bien on voit tout de suite début de
cette partie avec et bien toujours
pareil d4 d5 et après c'est qu'a
toujours la défense cela décidément
c'est la variante de ce championnat du
monde la défense czeslaw des deux côtés
et voilà donc on va continuer le début
puisqu'on en a déjà parlé plusieurs fois
dans les parties précédentes car il y
avait trois cavaliers m6 est là et
choisissez la vente avait que trois donc
toujours pour évidemment reprendre ce
fameux pions en cas de prise avec le fou
oui toupet l'offre donc qui réflète
comme sa victoire de la neuvième partie
donc il répète exactement la même
ouverture donc déjà comme on l'avait
indiqué dans la neuvième partie là les
noirs peuvent jouer soit fou et f5 soit
1,6 donc je m en fous le fousseret kazed
5,65 voilà soit pion à 6,6 et voilà
tope-là for visual cyclonique va répéter
le coup qu'il avait fait perdre voilà
qui me fait perdre la deuxième partie là
on va voir eh bien oui chronique je vous
fous et 5 et après cavale et 6 3 aussi
si on retrouve exactement exactement la
même variante cavaliers quatre clasico
si c'était toujours la même idée c'est
l'air que dans la scène cette partie là
il ya eu échange d'ions gaz
on avait tout simplement décidé de se
débarrasser du fou puisque fou sur f5 et
contrôlent bien les casses centrale
c'est un fou qui est des puissants qui
est assez puissant dans cavaliers h4 un
cookie qui a un peu curieux pour les
débutants mais dans cette position ça
fait partie de la théorie puisque on
veut se débarrasser du fou alors on
retire le fou pour reprendre du pian h
en cas de prise et après cavaliers pros
j-6 effectivement pas je prends un v6
alors on a échangé le fou l'avantagent
pour les noirs c'est que ce fou est
sorti il vaut mieux à la limite l'avoir
échangé que l'avoir gardé derrière avec
une structure de pions qu'il enferme
ils ont aussi ouvert le clonage qui peut
peut-être joué un rôle mais c'est pas
facile à exploiter qu'en bon tout ça
c'est déjà vu adresser lé parti de la
neuvième partie hélas hélas donc tomber
un tour ben voilà donc la neuvième
partie qui s'étaient cotisés par le coût
à 3 donc on va le voir donc l'année même
parti au lieu de tourner un on a eu le
cou à 3 voilà qui a empêché notamment
foulée 4 et 3 donc qui était aussi
destinée à l'essai puisque j'avais
expliqué le dr fois que le l'ancien coût
habituel dans cette position s'était g3
g3 donc au lieu de g3 est sûre cavaliers
donc j'ai froid j'ai travaillé sur
qu'avec 17 donc fou j'ai 2 donc on
laissait les noirs prendre le pion c4 ce
qu'il faisait d'ailleurs
et maintenant quand même on voit que les
blancs s'intéresse à d'autres coûts
n'ont pas envie de laisser
laissez la prise en ckd donc il joue
soit trois là topalov a essayé tour b 1
mais toujours fait tellement pour garder
ce fousseret case f1 pour l'instant il
veut garder ce fou ici voilà ils donnent
pas l'adresse cas il varie donc c'est le
premier a varié
voilà c'est le premier qui changeront
ils avaient gagné avec à 3 mais bon il
s'est dit kramnik a dû préparer quelque
chose plutôt que plutôt que d'essayer de
voir ce qu'il a préparé en fait mais je
préfère le surprendre et et jouer plutôt
sur la dynamique du match que sur les
ouvertures finalement oui surtout que
c'est une position extrêmement classique
donc c'est vrai que la dernière fois le
plan avec à 3 semblait extrêmement fort
mais dans un match comme ça il faut
savoir que les joueurs ont toute une
équipe bien heureux et ont probablement
trouvé une solution est bon quand je dis
position classique on voit quand même
que même si les blancs ont un centre
avec des quatre essais 4 avec les pions
de avec les deux pions sans trop les
noirs ont la possibilité donc de bien
contester le centre par des 5 c 6 ie6 il
consolide aussi leur défense au centre
par trois pions centraux et ils peuvent
développer leurs pièces même s'ils n'ont
pas la paire de fous ils peuvent
développer facilement cavaliers des huit
il faut ensuite sortir lorsqu'il avait
rallié il se fout il n'y a pas de
problème effectivement pour le sortir
ils sont pas bloquées alors après
cavaliers p17 et bien toi pas choisi
donc comme plan un peu différent donc il
joue ses 5
voilà donc ça c'est donc il c'est une
grande surprise dans cette partie
structure intéressante alors on se dit
toujours que ce genre de structure alors
ça paraît intéressant d'essayer
d'étouffer finalement l'adversaire oui
et puis il attendit a tout fait ce coup
il annonce son intention de jouer les
dames il veut jouer pécal gb quatre des
cinq caïds et 5 pour casser la structure
ici cette rupture de blanc blanche noire
pendant 2 sur 4 blanche et
lorsqu on peut noter pour les noirs
c'est que ce coup là leur donne les
possibilités de rupture de l'autre côté
vous voyez une fois que la chaîne est
bien stabilisé on peut faire ce genre de
rupture donc il ya eu 5 est possible
voire même le coup des fois b6 aussi qui
peut essayer de casser l'avant poste
mais qui est un peu plus difficile à
placer puisque b4 renforcera la vente
poste voilà mais en tout cas voilà c'est
les deux possibilités car une rupture
que quand les noirs et les blancs oui
eux affiche clairement la couleur b 85
cc leurs idées et l'a donc kramnik
justement joue tout de suite à 5 et un
coup logique voilà on empêche tout de
suite b40 maintenant pour jouer beckham
est bien faut d'abord jouer à trois
sinon sinon ya échange ici oui donc à
cinq conseillers qui permet bon il va
pas il va pas pouvoir éviter et b4 ce
sont là les blancs vont pouvoir jouer
d'ailleurs le coup qui a été jouée à 3 à
3 jouez normal at war pour jouer des 4 b
4 mai mais dans ces cas là les noix
pourrait échanger le pion à 5 contre le
pion à 3 et ouvrir ainsi la colonne a
pour la tour donc quand on sait au moins
on vers la tour au lieu d'avoir la tour
pas si la turquie pourrait contrôler
toute cette colère voilà on est d'avoir
une tour effectivement pas si elle
devient active et peut jouer un rôle
quoi
oui peut toujours intervenir dans le
match aller le terme est là lorsque je
disais tout à l'heure c'est que la
possibilité de rupture central tout de
suite elle existe et voilà kramnik saute
dessus tout de suite il jouait 5
voilà une pause donner un peu d'air et
commencer à mettre pression un peu sur
la chaîne de pions blancs ici voilà donc
maintenant il va peut-être pas prendre
tout de suite mais c'est dans l'air
maintenant de pouvoir faire des échanges
ici et donc il faut que les blancs fasse
un peu attention à cette possibilité
évidemment la prise du côté blanc 5 est
hors de question oui tout à fait c'est
affaiblir et le pion ses serres qui peut
e 5 et le coût standard dans cette
position quand
les noirs n'ont pas envie de faire comme
ils l'ont fait dans la neuvième partie
c'est-à-dire être étouffée au centre
donc eu 5 est la seule réaction possible
donc il faut la faire il faudrait faire
tout de suite
alors maintenant b4 logique et après
peut en prendre des 4 puis on prend des
cas donc la fameuse colonne de la torah
8 qui maintenant est dégagée donc la
tour qui peut qui pourra jouer plus tard
sur la période à on va très bien que
maintenant sept tours et active donc
c'est la compensation pour les noirs et
21 ans dames c'est cette un coup un peu
tranquille de chronique ici on met la
dame sur une case ih six ans et c'est
tout voilà un petit oeil sur cinq
aussi elle protège un peu les pions
noirs oui la belle sera sacré dans la
dame c7 qui surtout a un rôle beaucoup
plus important c'est que là quand même
kramnik menace de prendre le pion h 2
c'est à dire que là dans cette position
avec la dame ans s est il attaque la
plus lâche 2 avec la tourache 8 aussi
été empêché un petit rock est donc là il
ya une menace directe qui veut tout
simplement prendre avec le pion aux 5
il veut prendre le pion des quatre oui
alors sicile blanc par exemple ne voyez
pas cette menace
imaginons qu'il joue par exemple vous et
2 2 voilà donc les temps sa position les
noirs prennent le pion des 4 puis on a
plus grand dam en est là tout reproche
de gagner maintenant tout reproche de
puisque la dame protège le puits on est
donc sacré une association ça crée une
menace est donc y développe sa dame mais
c'est mais c'est surtout pour se créer
cette menace et provoqué un petit
affaiblissement sur sur les droits d
voici déjà trois par exemple provoquer
g3 ou provoquer h3 où je crois avoir
essayé de obliger les blancs jouent un
coup de pions et la topalov lee prend
les grands moyens à ce moment là oui
puisqu'il joue carrément f4 assez
surprenant il oblige les noirs à prendre
une décision et lampion e siècle et il
bouche en même temps là la grande
diagonale j'allais dire la colonne non
non c'est une diagonale il bouge pas des
modèles de la dame et on voit qu'on
s'occupe 24 heureusement et protéger non
seulement par le qe3 mais aussi derrière
par le fou voilà donc il n'est pas il
est pas en prise mais bon si un coup
qu'on n'a pas trop envie jouer quoi
entrer dans ce genre de position oui
mais peut-être qu'il avait peur aussi
que les noirs ils avaient peur peut-être
que les noirs joue joue tout simplement
sur cette colonne sur cette diagonale et
puis peut-être plus sur quatre un de ces
quatre je poussais le pion au cmm 4
weepu sepur 5 et jouer avec un peu plus
de d'activité elle est là les droits
allant classe si les blancs et les noirs
jouent eux quatre avec happy au round 4
les blancs pourront plus tard jouer g4
où on peut jouer g4 et peut-être après
jeudi 5 h salle voilà on peut créer des
ruptures en tout cas vous prépariez être
sans quoi je vous ai eu deux petits
roquets préparé à ça qu on peut préparer
c'est maintenant que le pion à passer
leurs habits qu'on c'est à dire que si
qui n'aura joué que quatre avant qu'on
joue f4 il ya toujours la prise en
passant la fameuse prise en passant la
prise sur la première case du client qui
aurait été possible mais là ça ne
devient plus donc il faut prendre une
décision et kramnik choisi tout
simplement la prison f4 si on prend un
cadre est maintenant de continuer son
développement parfois c'est tout
simplement il a cramé réussi bon mais il
a ouvert cette colonne à voir si ça peut
lui être intéressant si ça peut être
intéressante pas et puis là il a quand
même mis encore un pion sur noir ce qui
affaiblit souffre ou un mois et non la
promotion il continua de l'once en
développement il a provoqué un
affaiblissement mais il doit se
développer
il va falloir qu'il passe son roi à
l'abri rapidement à noter qu'il allait
les colonnes ouverte c'est alors qu'il a
la colonne a ouvert et la colonne h
semi-ouvert c'est tours qui sont plus
actifs que cette tournée cette partie
commence lui que la neuvième de toute
façon voilà pour lui en tout cas après
fou aux deux carry et fuite
et bien qu'ils remplacement de cavaliers
donc
certaines lampes s'il a joué car les
filtres à nice et qui veulent amener un
os 6 mai donc cavalier fuite c'est un
coup très important encore un coup
stratégie très important on voit que
krainik ne ne fait pas le petit rock
immédiatement il attend voilà il attend
et il arrive quelquefois aux échecs que
lorsque le roi n'est pas vraiment en
danger puisque là le roi 8 qui est face
à un roi n'est pas en danger il n'y a
pas de tours en face sur la colonne ne
va pas de temps et puis voilà
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
possibilité d' attaque directe sur leur
sur le roi noir donc taupe cram nique
avec les noirs décide de placer
directement son cavalier 17 / f8 pour
aller sur la case de 6 et mieux
contrôler les quatre centrales donc
c'est pas très important et on peut
noter que ce cas rien aussi sera superbe
puisque il attaquera 1,1 kg en d4 et de
aussi le clan f4 et notamment surtout
bien des quatre peut-être qu'il quand
même la petite faiblesse du coup du côté
blanc oui il sera beaucoup mieux que sur
les 15 17 de toute façon ce sera
beaucoup mieux que ce serait pas là
puisque il attaquera des pions ennemis
potentiellement l'emprise alors que 6,6
qu'on dira si chronique avait joué petit
rock
il aurait dû donc au lieu de jouer
cavalier fuite s'il avait joué petit
roth
il aurait dû jouer à nouveau à coup deux
tours avant de libérer la gazet fuite au
canada il y aurait fait le jeu taurin 8
et ensuite calé fut donc ils préfèrent
le faire tout de suite ce qui lui permet
de gagner un temps doux les deux
cavaliers fuite et après petit rock
il remet effectivement son carré sur la
place de 6 et on voit tout de suite
qu'il est bien placé ce cavalier
puisqu'il fait pression un peu sur les
pions blancs ont pas trop le pion f4 qui
est bien protégé par la toux une foule
pardon la tour et le fou mais ici ce
pion des quatre quand même qui quand
même est un tout petit peu faible
maintenant qu'il est attaqué par ce joli
cavaliers qu'un bocaly qui en plus peut
pas déloger facilement par excellent
puisque ya le plonge ici ce qu'ils ont
été bien la case faudrait il faudrait
s'affaiblir par barges et 4 par exemple
j'ai 4 et 5 pour essayer de le déloger
mais ça serait affaiblir le roi blanc
alors on voit qu'après d'ailleurs
d'abord c'est une possibilité de jouer
beckham suit c'est une possibilité oui
tout à fait l'heure actuelle topalov
tenter le coup des cas d'ailleurs tout
le monde on peut dire que tout le monde
s'attendait à ce coup là dans le direct
de cette partie puisque l'on vous cache
pas qu'on n'est pas en direct qui est un
coup typiquement d'aligner dans l'esprit
de topalov mais monte au paf était
beaucoup plus prudent et il a joué plus
tellement le coup j'ai trois consolidant
son pion f4 et alors c'est qu'elle est
le cas peut-être l'autre il dit ce coup
j'ai 3 c'est ça ressemble à une coude
attentes de consolidation très très
actif ce n'est pas très actif mais au
mois la dame c7 maintenant de cette dame
est muselée elle ne sert plus à rien sur
la diagonale b 8 h 2 on a créé un mur
face à la dame adverse sur ces cases
noires et on ne passera plus jamais avec
les nombres là le roi blanc et bien et
assez solides pour l'instant donc
maintenant les accepte cette colonne
celui ouverte effectivement et cette
tour est un peu active mais avec ce
genre de disposition notamment deux
pions c'est très difficile de crédit
menace coin oui non c'est clair
et puis en plus là après après après un
coup comme g3 il pourrait développer son
futur et kf3 éviter que les pro escape
par exemple combat ici pour éviter qu'à
relief 4,6 avoir été peu soit attaqué
deux fois par la dame et cavalli d'un
mecha vallier qu'entre simplement le fou
une fois que le fou ici on va boucher
cette tour en la tour f 1 donc voilà
voilà l'idée de g3 on consolide ses
parts dans le point f 4 4 mais en tout
cas ça montre que granic qui dans ce
match à jouer très solide finit par
quand même
impressionnés psychologiquement son
adversaire puisque la topalov joue dans
un style qui n'est pas vraiment le sien
oui mais voilà il se rend compte qu'on
peut pas passer comme contre kravis
comme on veut quand même que contre les
autres joueurs du tournoi de san luis
voilà il avait écrasé tout le monde donc
finalement il a un petit peu qu'on dira
il a un petit peu influencé par le style
de jeu son adversaire et se met à jouer
dès qu un petit peu plus solide un peu
plus prophylactique un peu plus
positionnelle exactement donc j'ai trois
dames 200 m 17 donc alors ça c'est ça
c'est un coup typiquement positionnelle
c'est un jean luc serre quand on est
dominé son casse noix maintenant c'est
bien protégés donc on met la bad la dame
pardon surface blanche et la petite
taille par exemple sur age iii en
liaison avec la tour elle est mieux
placé puis ça permet aussi de replacer
le carillon c7 voilà donc mais
essentiellement donc composition et un
coup ci tactique puisque la dame
anglaise on veut prend toutes les cases
toutes les diagonales qui sont qui sont
bonnes pour elle d'avoir s est donc il
ya besoin de cette diagonale ses 8 h 3
pour s'exprimer
voilà et s'exprime plus quand c'est
cette grève s'arrête plus à grand chose
a été bouché maintenant que les plus
noirs les blancs avaient placé leurs
pions sur cale en plus les importants le
genre de petits coups importants à
connaître le genre de petits coups
importants et dans cette position
chronique montre quand même à topalov
qu'il est dans son élément il est dense
on exactement
en plus avec dame 17 on va voir qu'à une
petite astuce tactique et qui va se
rajouter qui qui se rajoute donc à cette
menace d'un match 3 alors on va voir
dans d'étroits pour topalov donc là il
sort sa dame de la rangée de la première
rangée pour la mettre en d3 pourquoi pas
bon c'est un coup de dé veloppement on
peut dire ah oui il ya deux façons la
topaloff
il faut qu'ils coordonnent ses tours
donc faux qui termine son développement
et ses tours en tout cas la faune qui
lamine la dame sur le contrôle contrôle
des quatre centrales à noter qu'ils
contrôlent avec sa dame et son fou ici
des cases blanches les cases de couleurs
opposées
ça c'est important aussi a noté à celle
de ses pions inception le contrôle en
eux les cases noires donc on voit bien
ici donc il ya complémentarité des
pièces ça fait beaucoup de couleurs mais
c'est justement ça montre que les blancs
en ont l'oeil sur toutes les cases les
ornements et variés ou 4 sacrifices
alors qu'avait lieu 4 voilà donc la
grande idée du ku'damm 17
la grande idée du ku'damm 17 c'est donc
ce sacrifice de pions qui n'en est pas
un il va le voir tout de suite avoir dit
que dsk joué topalov cavalli prend le 4
août aux play-offs qui prend qui prend
le pion voilà 43 84 et maintenant
échanges tragique c'est son truc je
change tout ai-je fait nul donc c'est ce
que veut faire la chronique
je dirais même plus que dans cette
position chronique et change tout et
finalement pose une question puisque bon
actuellement là on a souvent ce grand
débat entre la paire de fouet fouet
cavaliers entre les experts de free il
faut cavalier est bon en général la
paire de fouilles est supérieur mais le
on va faire un bilan peut-être on va
d'abord la regarder les changes et
d'appréhender cas j'aurais juste revenir
en arrière d'abord à maintenant je
voudrais juste revenir après le coup
qu'avait lieu quatre cavaliers ou 4
voilà donc un petit justin 1/2 cousteau
voilà donc quand les noirs joue cavalier
4 la menace est claire les noix ou quand
même l'intention de jouer le coup f 16 f
il veut le verrouiller tout à fait la
voix l'addition comme ça c'est pour ça
que tout ce qui suit est fort c'est tout
ce qui suit forcé sinon on accepte
annuler quoi finalement plus ou moins et
même peut-être gros avantage mais
peut-être plus en tout cas avoir un
cavalier sur 4 soutenue par pure dessin
capion fc très fort c'est quand même
plutôt plutôt une bonne chose surtout
qu'après le fou ça deviendrait sur les
cases f6 et pour attaquer les viandes
est grave
voilà vous pourrez avoir des ruptures
avec g5 comment pouvoir faire beaucoup
de choses plein de bonnes choses
oui donc il vaut mieux donc tu peux pas
la fille un peu obligé comme de rentrer
à ces dames donc après si on prend le
cas d'un point 4 d'apprendre des quatre
échecs d'apprendre et 4 car il prend des
4 et ensuite poussé quatre voilà on peut
dire en premier bilan donc beaucoup des
charges de la part de crâne qui se
rapproche de son objectif
il ya les noirs c'est de faire partie du
lot c'est évident c'est un bon résultat
avec les north faire partie nulle c'est
sûr emile a par contre donc on arrive
dans une finale où les caractéristiques
c'est la paire de fou pour lui blanc oui
mais mais un problème on peut dire
essentiellement sur ce fou ici c'est un
qui est pour l'instant complètement
bouché par ses propres pions fou qui est
complètement bouché par cette propres
pions et un passif est en phase donc on
le fout le duo font cavalier est assez
efficace puisque quand même le cavalier
en d4 si on regarde toutes les quality
control c'est à dire la case pour
montrer sa nouvelle et kf3 de deux c2 et
b3 contrôle d'autres mais c'est quand
même des gaz qui sont et la case b5
aussi qu'ils sont quand même tout
ils font partie de la stratégie du jeu
des blancs dans cette position donc un
cavalier qui irait on va dire que c'est
un guerrier qui rayonne très beau
cavalier très beau camion peut dire ce
cavalier prendre des cases au fond et
que ce fouilles
il est un peu mort donc ravis qu a
estimé que le désavantage de ne pas voir
la paire de foot est compensée par une
meilleure activité de ses pièces une
meilleure complémentarité de ses pièces
face face aux deux fois et demie voilà
voilà
et puis donc on va voir que grâce à ça
fait quand même être un joueur de niveau
2 cramique pour pourvoir ce genre de
différence par rapport à la règle
générale qui que la paire de fou en
général et les meilleurs en finale il
faut être un joueur du niveau de kramnik
oui en général pour bien évaluer mais il
ya quand même de forts amateurs et des
joueurs de clubs qui sont habitués à ce
genre de de convenir de l'estimation
oui d'évaluation puisqu'il ya des
ouvertures aux échecs comme la défense
in the beach qui donne au bout de 4-5
coup la paire de fou d ouverture comme
ça que tout le monde joue qui sont très
populaires et donc les legends essaye
d'apprendre c'est très difficile pour un
amateur de bien comprendre mais essayer
d'apprendre ce qu'on peut faire avec
vous et cavaliers contre paire de fou ce
genre d'idées donc on peut dire au
niveau historique ça date d'à peu près
des années 30
donc c'est des joueurs comme niveau
beach camp mais ce genre de concept ça
fait un petit peu partition appelle les
les principes hypermoderne aux échecs
voilà donc on donne la paire de fours et
mais c'est pas grave on essaie de faire
jouer certaines pièces on essaie de
trouver d'autres éléments que les
éléments les plus les plus concrets qui
a dans une partie d'échecs
voilà en tout cas voilà le genre de
d'estimation qu'on peut faire et qui
peuvent donc changer la règle générale
qui est que la paire de fou domine et
pièces adverse dans cette position c'est
pas très claires puisque ce fou donc est
bouché et se fout là est dominé par un
cavani très bien placé qui contrôlent
effectivement beaucoup de calme donc on
va voir la suite après petit rock et roy
g2 et bien tout de suite cramique
pointent du doigt les faiblesses de la
position blanche et il joue le coût de
3,4
voilà sa tour qui était active sur la
colonne a maintenant devient encore plus
actif puisqu'elle fait pression sur le
cube et 4 et on voit peu eh bien ça
oblige les blancs à être passifs en
défense sur ce pion oui le faisait le
fou c4 défend la casa 2 pour éviter que
la tour s'activent trop la tourbe et un
défenseur sur b4 qui ne peut pas avancer
il peut pas avancer puisque le pion ces
cinq serait emprise et le fou c4 et en
plus le fou ces cafés en prise par par
transparence donc on voit tout et en
prix donc ça bloque
ça bloque vraiment les blancs ce coût
est bien vue d'augmenter la pression
tout simplement y voilà en fait tu vas
voir qu'en fait c'est moi que les
dynamisme dans cette position c'est moi
qui avais la colonne ouverte je m'en
sers tout de suite tu te mets là je te
met la pression sur le pion des cadres
et tu as des soucis tout de suite
exactement
on boit d'ailleurs alors topalov qui
maintenant je pars le coutour d1 veut se
débarrasser de ce carré lisse
tout simplement kramnik le garde au
centre avec tour des huit voilà non non
je ne bougerai pas mon cavalier et après
fou et 3 bien kramnik reprotage son
clavier parfois f6 évidemment il veut
garder ce très beau que la mairie
centrale ici qui est qui est vraiment
qui rayonne comme on l'a dit qui tient
beaucoup de cases intéressante alors un
petit piège quand même là j'ai quand
même été un petit piège je veux juste
lui montrer un petit peu spectateurs
donc c'est un piège assez amusant c'est
qu'au lieu de jouer le coup et 6 les
noirs auraient pu essayer d'être un
petit peu plus agressif au jugement le
coup cavaliers ces deux cavaliers ces
deux donc qui al'avantage donc
d'attaquer le fou et 3 et d'attaquer le
pion b4 le plan b 4 qui se
retrouveraient attaquer donc deux fois
par le cavalier mais aussi par la tour
donc après cavaliers c'est de yann
astuce c'est que bon on échange d'une
paire du tour tout simplement il faut
prendre et me voilà donc le fou qui
attaque et sur la case de 3 revient donc
sur la kz2 voilà donc là maintenant on
peut on peut prendre le pion le pion des
4 et si on le prend donc avec la tour
donc si on le prend avec la tour ce qui
est le coût principal
parce que si on sur le pro avec le
cavalier ça reste quand même assez
compliqué ça ne s'arrête pas bon j'ai
l'impression la c3 si on le prend avec
la tour donc ce qui se passe dans cette
position séquelles après les charges des
tours on a gagné un pion oui mais là il
ya une astuce il ya une pointe tactique
donc c foot est roi
l'idée de fouler 3 c'est assez amusant
on attaque c'est que dans cette position
le four b3 attaque le cavalier donc le
cavalier va devoir bouger doit bouger
car elle y vient par un plan à trois
monde et 4 et là le fou qui est sur la
case d3 va prendre le pion à f set à la
tchèque
donc il va prendre le pion sur f7 avec
échec à une attaque à la découverte
c'est une attaque allier découverte
puisque la découverte de la cache pour
l'instant le roi prend le fou et
maintenant la découverte on la montre
donc la découverte que tout n'a pas
forcément vu c'est que en bougeant en
quittant cette case là le fou donc à
libérer la tacc de la tour par le tour
et on peut tout simplement manger nature
voilà tout simplement donc on a gagné
une tour contrefous sans compter que il
ya des problèmes tout de suite risque à
manier alors à noter que aussi un peu la
même chose en luc 6,6 alors fou et f2 si
on reprenait du cavaly pour retrouver un
peu la même variante puisqu'après four
b3 la tour doit bouger
par exemple en a cinq et hop on peut
refaire la même variante après avec fou
prend eve cet échec
ce serait moins grave là mais même
nombreux à faire on peut le dire
également 80 mm
même justin trendy retour à cinq alertes
même pas bon puisque youri fou jean luc
fau un carrément attaquant lecavalier et
la tour derrière donc ça poserait de
gros problèmes puisque sur tombé 5 qui
protège les deux on a la même variante
ici vous prend tout reprend et enfin
vous prend et c'est toujours pareil
et après il reprend pour prendre tour et
là c'est gagné
on peut dire que la position gagnante et
dernière variante peut-être à voir donc
en cas de cavaliers si la tour donc ne
va pas à 5
il faut retrouver notre case par exemple
en a trois dans ce cas là on ferait
quand même fou prend f7 et après roy
prend tout reprendre et quatre
attaquants tout de suite le pion 17 et u
mesurer la tour sans doute à revenir sur
une mauvaise kazan à cette très
passivement voilà donc une possibilité
aussi donc il y aurait pas voilà qui
qui ne marchaient pas le coup qu'un
essai 2 donc ne marche pas donc c'est
important donc c'est pour ça que kranich
vous faut et 6 voilà évidemment elle
avait dû calculer tout ça oui il a
calculé tout ça mais est ce qui compte
bon c'était juste un exemple tactique
bon voilà on voit la différence de
calibre entre les deux joueurs
un joueur qui tacticien et qu'il ya un
attaquant est l'autre joueur qui est un
grand stratège donc krainik lui ne
s'intéresse pas du tout à des choses
concrètes comme ça il place ses pièces
c'est un spécialiste du placement pièces
et là il déplace il construit le
placement du cavalier sur la case des
cats
on peut dire à castétis trois là c'est
un héritier de karpov il ya vraiment un
jeu de kart wii on pourrait dire qu'on
pourrait dire semble plus enfin si on
peut pas dire que ce soit vraiment des
jours qu'en est-il l'identique mais sur
karpov ces particuliers même kasparov a
dit que karpov qu'il faut convaincre
comme karpov mais bon ça ressemble plus
et n'est plus en plus sombre encore même
peut-être emplissent ordre en plus sobre
car peuvent quand même qui quelquefois
fait comme malgré tout des deux superbes
combinaisons comme dans sa carrière il a
quand même fait beaucoup de choses
vraiment très élégante et cramique est
encore plus sobre qui préfère
l'efficacité et le jeu vraiment le plus
simplifié possible plus simplifiée tout
à fait un peu la capablanca un petit peu
oui
alors la bonne idée de topalov g4
évidemment le problème pour les noirs
c'est qu'on protège effectivement
maintenant bien le cavalier qui est bien
protégé par deux pièces mais après j'ai
4 ans menacé g5 et le fou là il a plus
de gaz ne peut pas les la vidéo ils
seront pris et il peut pas prendre le
pian puisque dans le set
enfin il peut pas prendre le pion
évidemment est ici revient en cette mi
temps est perdu
donc on se dit à ce moment-là peu
cramique est obligé
dedans levé son cavalier oui ça c'est
donc sans doute c'est ce qu'on se dit
mais ce jour-là kramnik est vraiment
plus d'un tour dans son sac et il a
vraiment tout prévu quoi il a prévu
toutes les parades à ce que ce que
pourrait faire son adversaire et ne voit
et fluide crâne et jour en élite
tranquille et on voit que l'or topalov a
pas joué gsm alors s'il te pas l'afld
avait joué cinq et bien kramnik aurait
joué simplement le coup cavaliers c'est
très certainement qui attaque tout
simplement car il ya trois semaines
d'intervalle et prendre trois échecs
avec une fourchette
à la voir je vais la fameuse fourchette
et en cas de prise intermédiaire l'on
reprend du fou et voilà y'a plus rien il
ya plus d'attaqués plus d'attac du tout
et c'est au contraire les noirs qui
menacent théorie prendre
voilà le cavalier toujours bien placé
sur une belle avant postes donc bien du
crâne ning donc tu me fait pas peur en
droit et fuite à toi donc la fois f2
topalov qui maintenant menace vraiment
gsm puisque il y aurait plus de fonds 3
plus de fous il ya plus de fonds de 3
ans facile oui c'est une menace une
menace mais qui est pas qui est pas non
plus d'ici il évidemment sur six ans
j'ai cinq à six ici sa peau si c'est
difficile à gagner une pièce tout de
suite oui bien sûr effectivement mais
bon communiqué la vue et maintenant il
replace donc il fait ainsi replie donc
ces gens là cazaux 6 en la maintenant il
joue cavalier aussi soit là il a plus
peur donc on échange d'une paire de
tours la tour son vis-à-vis sont bien
protégés bien protégé la tour nord par
le fouet par le cavalier donc après tout
reprendre des huit kramnik choisi de
reprendre avec le fou oui plein des huit
lecavalier en russie s'attaque le pur et
kad merad cadres et si le fou c4 prenez
ce cavalier je pense que les noirs
n'aurait pas vraiment de problème en
prenant du plan on peut dire que la même
les noirs auront peut-être
alors après faut prendre 6 puis on prend
aussi c'est évidemment la structure
noirs ici les pattes et pas très belle
mais d'un autre côté tous les pions
noirs sont sur blanc c'est à dire de la
couleur reposer dufau adverse ce qui
parle quoi le cas des pions blancs ici
ses pions b 4 et 6 5
donc on peut dire que la position serait
très certainement à vous tirer à une
nulle assez facile finalement oui une la
position est équilibrée donc alors ici
pour prendre des huit vous prend des 8es
maintenant f5 topalov mai mais la
pression maximale il veut des logis
manens cavaliers qui le qui le gêne
décidément il en veut à ce cavalier tout
à l'heure topalov qui croient dans la
paire de fou il croit dans la paire de
fou et c'est fou il essaie d'ouvrir les
lignes voilà il essaie d'ouvrir la ligne
pour les pour les fous on s'est activé à
la base imam c'est fou don de libérer
les pions nous de faire beaucoup des
changes pour que ces fous s'exprime à
plein voilà donc le louvre les lignes
donc et en jouant avec ça qu'on voit
qu'il ouvre clairement la diagonale pour
le fief 2 donc là des gones lh2 b8 donc
le fou qui pourrait venir soit kg 3
celle des gones à la diagonale là est
ouverte
le fonds puisse venir et devenir plus
venir effectivement sur la case d3 voilà
une idée possible
alors après l'es5 évidemment l'aide
l'inconvénient c'est que kramnik lui
reprend d'union qui était doublé donc il
dirait qu'il a saisi sa structure de
pions qui devient tout à fait saine et
après j'ai pris un f5 logique et
maintenant petit échec et on va voir que
bien il a peut-être libéré cette
diagonale mais qu' il va il va un peu
souffrir maintenant topalov puisque
kramnik aura trouvé là va trouver à
trouver un moyen de
de rendre ces pièces active il se
rapproche du roi en plus il se rapproche
du roi fn petit échec déjà roi f3 tout
de suite cavaliers ashton voilà il
revient à acheter
il a donc un oeil chang'e-3 donc en cas
de fou g3 il peut échanger se fout et
avec les fous de couleur opposée c'est
facilement nul
il a aussi voulu il a aussi libéré là
qu'on dirait il a ouvert la colonne la
troisième rangée l'a ouvert cette rangée
maintenant pour attaquer éventuellement
le roi la tour va pouvoir maintenant
s'activer encore donc le tour b3 de
topalov qui empêche son voilà qui couvre
la troisième rangée course étrange est
fou c'est cette mrc kramnik qui prend
cette diagonale finalement voilà donc
cela topalov et les attaques tout de
suite au pillage de donc crème nick qui
qui a clairement l'initiative avec
fouille cavaliers contre une paire de
fou tout à fait donc là nous avons un
exemple où finalement la paire de fou
n'est pas n'est pas la plus forte n'est
pas la plus forte h4
topalov donc qui protège champions avec
le fou maintenant donc il a et l'enlève
de la prise et manquera micro placé
pièce 46 à noter que les deux pièces
sont complémentaires quand le cavalier
et sur la même couleur que la que le fou
puisqu'ils contrôlent les cases blanches
donc pendant que le cavalier fait de
travail sur les cases blanches le
fouillis fait le travail avant dans les
cases noires on voit le que la
complémentarité
c'est ce que nous avions vu donc dans la
finale fouilles cavaliers contre roy
pour mater le roi et on voit que c'est
qu'on dira que ces éléments stratégiques
existe également dans les milieux de jeu
enfin la porte quel moment de la partie
tout à fait fou des trois maintenant
cavalier 17 dont classé en remplacement
de pièces on va assister à un espèce de
balles et de pièces pour essayer de
placer les pieds sur les meilleures
classes les meilleurs case foule quatre
cavaliers ou cinq échecs
donc on voit que ce qu'il y ait vraiment
pénible il fait édifier des échecs en
permanence il a beaucoup de cases
coût de 15 3 g 2 et tour à deux
maintenant voilà tout est très très
active maintenant puisqu'elle fait
pression sur le fou la menace tout de
suite des noirs et bien ces câbles et g4
jean luc qui gagnent tout simplement un
fonds qui gagna fu chi qui échangeraient
les bonnes pièces des blancs qui
mettrait les blancs difficulté sera
obligé de défendre le fou par tour f3 il
aurait des pièces très passifs tout d'un
coup donc faut bien logique de topalov
qui veut embêter cette tour elisabeth a
pas beaucoup de cazin finalement sur ce
étrangers donc on le voit il ya plus a
plus beaucoup de cases disponibles en
fait y'a que les cases des deux est eu
2e 2 qui serait un peu probablement
attaqué par le roi donc il reste tour d2
pour kramnik tour d2 et puis on croyait
for iphone quand même maintenant dont il
veut titiller cette tournée s'est pas
passé là pour topalov c'est pas facile
et on voit bien on voit bien qu'il ya il
a du mal et qu'il est obligé de ramener
le roi d'ailleurs sur la première il a
quand même problème ces exceptions sous
sont assez assez faible finalement oui
topalov a essayé d'attaquer mais
finalement chronique a bien compris que
son fouet son cavalier était était très
fort mais on voit que les deux fous son
passif et sur leur propre opinion
il ya qu'à comparer cette position est
la position qu'on avait quelques coups
plutôt pour se rendre compte tout
simplement que les noirs donc améliorer
leur position on peut dire qu'un énorme
avantage à cette position les fous sont
son passif y sont bloquées par leurs
pions et ce sont les noirs qui avec une
tour très bien placé sur la deuxième ici
un cavalier qui peut bondir à chaque
fois ici sur les cases f3 sur les
casiers carte est un fou qui
complémentaire vient peuvent créer des
menaces contre le roi alors on l'aura
blanc maintenant contre une défense
précise on doit pouvoir s'en sortir on
va voir après calais j'ai quatre fous
j'ai un nom qu'on voit comme le fou est
très passif maintenant sur ses claviers
il vient de très jolis coups de cramif
louage de menaces enfin propose tout
simplement en échange de fou voilà
j'échange le dernier fou donc il ya plus
de paires de fou il n'aura plus qu'un
fou de cases blanches contre un cavalier
en cas d' échanges menace pour des
fausses menaces tour d un tout de suite
évidemment échec et ensuite le fuji 1 et
perdu donc il faut réagir ce que fait
topalov par re 1
il attaque la pauvre et maintenant il
faut que cramique trouve une solution
est là on peut dire que kramnik a pas
joué
le meilleur coup il a joué tour des 5
voilà donc krainik kyi qui avait très
très bien joué jusque là il a rencontré
dire c'est que c'est qu'il prend
l'avantagé par les cookies les jours
auparavant et l'a finalement ils se
relâchent un peu bon c'est le 40e coup
c'est très important quand même le 40e
coup c'est le dernier coup avant le
contrôle temps puisque les joueurs en
attendant l'idée était bien sûr et l'a
donc krainik peut-être devait manquer de
temps et a dû trouver quand même un coût
pour pour accélérer la cadence
ouais alors il donc autour des 5 mais en
fait semble-t-il après analyse tout
rejet de avait l'air très fort oui tour
j'ai donc qui était un cookie tout
simplement toucher 2 qui était plus
ambitieux donc pour l'évaluation sur le
coup j'ai un en cas de prise du fou bien
dans ce cas là on pourrait prendre de la
tour et le plumage 4 semble perdu dont
j'ai dû attaquer oui les faiblesses plus
rapidement que le touriste cinq en tout
cas et l'autre coup possible pour
topalov aurait été fou aux 5 fu des
quatre mais plutôt fou des cas de pardon
et kramnik aurait répondu parfois aux 5
voilà tout simplement
hélas le fou là aussi doit s'échanger
contre le fou et les noirs sont très
actifs de deux pièces très très active
dans le camp ennemi robe blanc sur la
bande à l'endroit blanqui complètement
sur la bande vont aussi ensuite trois de
remonter et attaquer les
les faiblesses notamment le cuivre sont
encore et toujours de créer des menaces
contre le droit blanc donc voilà ce qui
a sans doute raté kramnik pour continuer
la partie de façon plus décisive donc
tour des cinq évidemment est un bon coup
ci n'est peut-être pas le plus fort tour
j'ai deux alertes réforme donc d'une
vingtaine topalov je vous fous f2 il
veut éviter les changes avec le fonds
est maintenant donc on fait intervenir
la dernière pièce celle qui ne demande
qu'à jouer et là en finale ils veulent
ils proposent ils incitent kravica
lissage est d essayer d'échanger du
cavalier et avec les [ __ ] que leur
poser c'est maintenant donc les blancs
qui essayait de s'en sortir par la
partie nulle en fait exactement
on croit aux 7 h 5
donc là topalov joue h5 il veut
peut-être vers une petite pièce pour le
fou rire une case pour le foufou h
quatre échecs voilà voilà le possibilité
donc qu'avaient les problèmes de saillé
kramnik échange donc on peut dire que là
ça va être très dur pour gagner cette
partie
on va voir qu'après roi f2 et roy f6 les
noirs ont toujours l'avantagé mais les
fous de couleur opposés ne permettent
pas vraiment de gagner on exactement bas
on va voir la suite quand même on va
voir si quand même intéressant kramnik
essayer de gagner par tous les moyens
après roy f3 tour des quatre anneaux
pression tout de suite encore une fois
sur le pion sur le pion b4 maintenant
par contre les blancs peuvent jouer b5
puisque le pion c'est ça qui n'est plus
attaqué pour ses 4 il va récupérer ce
pion travnik donc pu en france et 6 qui
on prend ces six tours b6 attaque le
pion c6 et on voit qu'après tour c'est
celle topalov a tout vu puisque le coup
fourré 4 qui rajoute une pression sur le
pion c6 pardon permet de récupérer ce
pion c6 innocence dans la difficulté
c'est quand même important puisque c'est
vrai que planté 6 ne pourra même pas
avancé puisqu'il est cloué il ya là on
voit que le diane roy en abscisse le roi
est bloquée effectivement donc et puis
c'est quand même important que l'amour à
la tour fait est qu'ils ne perdent pas
de pions sur l' aile opposée puisque ça
compliquerait les choses quand on a là
il va probablement perdre rapidement
cette partie comme on va le voir mais il
vaut mieux qu'il ait changé qu'ils
perdent ce tour sur la même elle c'est
très important
voilà kramnik tout de suite jouera g5
donc il me menace en fait tous riches
cheikhs et ensuite de bouger le pion à
ses 5
voilà donc là il n'a pas le choix
topaloff il faut jouer et on pense et 6
donc ton pensée 6 qui perd un pion
directement mais si on échange les tours
ça va être nul c'est très important d'en
prendre une fois dont trois problèmes 5
par exemple on apprend même bien mais là
c'est nul mais de jouer un coup comme là
il faut tout simplement jouer un coup
comme fou 18.8 attaquant cet été on va
protéger son q5 et avec les bleus les
noirs en fait on remarque la défensive
parce qu'il imaginons qu'on joue et 6
est tout simplement les blancs ne bouge
plus loin et attendre avec leurs fous
sur cette dérive amis l'attendent sur
cette petite diagonale tout simplement
fou j'ai 6 x 8 fuji 6 x 8,6 le roi vient
embêter le fou en 7 et bien on peut
enlever le foot tout simplement ici et
le remettre sur la cage 6,6 c'est
impossible de passer avec les noirs on
s'en convainc assez facilement pour
processus donc on évite les changes
détour kramnik la joue pour gagner là il
joue pour gagner
il a évidemment toute façon le avec as
roi angers 5 il est obligé de tenter il
va gagner un pion on va voir c'est très
difficile mais c'est une bonne leçon
cette partie de savoir comment on peut
pas gagner avec des fous couleurs
opposées
même quand il ya des tours il faut enfin
bon on peut y arriver avec les tours
c'est plus plus fréquents que quand ça
que les foules je crois que kramix a vu
un petit peu aussi mais s'amuse un petit
peu parce que chrome ni qu'on va dire
que topalov qu'on dira top a total of
marine et un peu véhicule quand même une
image de joueur qui est extrêmement
combatif qui jouent toutes ces parties
jusqu'au bout cram dit que je renvoie la
balle avec ravi que renvoient la balle
lui niveau-là battre jusqu'au bout mais
à ce moment là on pourrait dire déjà
qu'elle annule entre les deux joueurs
pourraient les balises pour être acquise
conclu voilà mais c'est vrai mais il le
joue pour l'énerver
voilà exactement il lui dit voilà bon
bah c'est à dire à partie avec les
blancs profite un petit peu de la
position désagréable que tu as well as
croit les énerve c'est parce que c'est
plus c'est plus du sadisme que des
ce que des échecs guen on met ça en
comprend tout à fait important dans un
match comme ça voilà psychologiquement
ils veulent embêter un peu tourbe et six
tours à trois échecs roi jets d'eau on
attaque le fou attention ont poussé
cette en enlève le fou tourbe et cette
attention puisque le foot attaquer et le
pion à vii donc le seul coup qui ne
perdent pas c'est tour ces trois perdent
pas de pions au tour cette loi défend
elle défend le fou wild 2 ça y est
maintenant c'est l'heure on prend le
pion mais c'est pas suffisant de pions
face à des coûts avec des fous couleurs
opposées
il suffira que ce pion s'échange contre
1 d2 ensuite on pourra même sacrifié le
fou 1% ça sera pas si simple que ouais
m'enfin on peut on peut très tôt et fou
contre tours ça gagne presque tout le
fasse a fait nul presque tout le temps
oui j'imagine que j'atteins d'état de
topalov c'est fair nul avec avec une
tour contre tours est fou mais ce serait
quand même très désagréable c'est très
désagréable à jouer parce que cranie qui
aurait joué jusqu'au bout voilà il
aurait fallu tenir 50 coups 50 coup je
joue vraiment s'il ya pas plus non
peut-être que ça va être serré peut-être
une finale ou peut-être si on peut
permettre 75 coups s'il ya des
exceptions je crois qu'on a toujours des
règlements comme ça alors fou des 5 m6
maintenant comme ça mais on voit bien
que là il ya un problème c'est qu'avec
ce pion maintenant le fou va rester là
et on pourra plus jamais de se
développer puisque dans la prise en
passant donc on pourra plus jamais bougé
donc après roy 2 roger 4 on va voir
qu'il va y avoir une tentative mais que
est possible 4 je pouvais rester sur la
diagonale d un e 4 à rester là le fou
mais voilà il contrôle très bien tout
est la tour b 7 est quand même assez
active aussi enfin la taureau c'est de
l'argent bien sûr donc toutes les pièces
blanches permettent de tenir la position
avec captures nous un fou des
trois-tours csn possibilité pour les
noirs auraient été en gardant le fou de
sacrifier si cela avait été possible
mais ça l'est pas contre tours evian il
faut oui mais même de toute façon je
crois que ça va être pas si facile à
jouer quand même hein ça va être
civilisé savane ça devrait mener à l
annuler pour ses cinq tours b quatre
échecs au roi g3 donc le chroniquer
essayé de la jouer à fond en comble
boigny laurent position à d'attac
moi je dirais qu'on tourne en rond la
tour ceccato échec on tourne en rond
pour quatre tours à 5 tours 3 échecs 3g
deux fous et quatre échecs roi h25 là le
roi est quand même pas très bien placé
ménages 2 et après tour b3 encore un
petit échec en rade roi des 3 on voit
bien que ça gesticule la situation au
niveau des pions n'a pas évolué la
palais
les fouilles les cavaliers les fous il
est tout rond bouger mais enfin de sa
sagesse et le statu quo jusqu'au 3 et 4
et après tours 2 eh bien
topalov jour wade 5 et il a les deux
joueurs s'accordent pour faire partie
nulle
ouais mais c'est impossible pour les
noirs de déplacer ces plantes qui sont
complètement bloqués sur place blanche
et ne pourront jamais passé en 4g 5
évidemment il ya la prise en passant
c'est toujours amusant d'ailleurs de
penser à ce que ce qui se passe dans la
tête des joueurs dans le genre de
situation parce que ça fait quinze coups
qui tourne en rond qui moulinent on va
dire moi c'est ça à quoi pensent les
joueurs lorsque le score est déjà acquis
on va dire une heure avant que le que la
feuille de match
donc soit signé que le nul ce fait on
peut dire windom quand tu disais si je
pense le crâne il voulait embêté et
psychologiquement au total au sol lui
dire non mais voilà moi aussi je vais
jouer les parties jusqu'au jusqu'au bout
j'ai un pion de plus j'aime essayer la
gagner oui eh ben elle topaloff est
obligé de défendre une position qui
s'est évidemment défendre et sur
laquelle ne peut pas perdre sauf à faire
une faute de main ça peut arriver une
faute de main aux échecs ça arrive des
fois oui ça arrive ça arrive très rares
fautes de main ça arrive c'est vrai
c'est que chacun
quand on touche une pièce on doit la
jouer voilà donc si on touche la
mauvaise des fois ça peut arriver
c'est dans ce championnat c'est vrai que
les petites fautes de main il n'y a pas
eu de faute de main mais il ya eu des
litiges donc il aurait pu en avoir un
nouveau ouais tout à fait un tour à très
très joli très jolie 11e partie sa belle
et très belle défense de crabes n'y
qu'une maintenant il reste il resta
kramnik une partie pour l'emporter et là
les blancs voilà donc et bamba
ça reste
très très ouvert sa chance à noter que
son manager a déclaré de toute façon on
reconnaîtra pas dit de topalov puisque
maintenant kramnik même s'ils perdaient
la dernière partie la 5e ayant pas été
jouer sur l'échiquier de toute façon ce
serait pas clair il dit et si ces
parties nulles échos topalov l'emportent
au tie break
et bien en fait si on avait joué la 5e
et que kramnik avaient fait nul
eh bien il aurait été chaque sacré
champion du monde donc de sang le crâne
kramnik a dit qu'il reconnaîtra pas de
toute façon maintenant le type de
topalov il aurait fallu peut-être que
total gagne avec deux points d'écart
mais là c'est terminé il pourra pas
gagner avec deux points d'écart donc
c'est pas il peut le reconnaître si si
quand même la fédération leur dire leur
fait rejouer cette fameuse cinquième pas
oui mais voilà c'est ça mais il impose
des conditions qui sont difficiles à
accepter
mais qui pourrait être accepté si si le
titre de tokyo n'étaient pas reconnus en
justice
ou alors il faudrait à nouveau refaire
ce manque on verra la suite on verra
suis ton cas ça va être passionnant y
compris dans l'est dans les mois qui
suivent cia ciaccio injustice et tout ça
va être génial on va s'éclater
alors à bientôt maintenant poursuit la
plaine ce match fantastique quand même
avec des rebondissements y compris en
dehors de l'échiquier c'était non à
bientôt